This video is brought to you by mischief.
Hey wisecrack, somehow even longer haired Jared here and today,
we're talking about a movie that bitterly divides the wisecrack team.
We've spent hours going back and forth on our self isolated Skype calls on
whether the film is deep or dumb.
Zack Snyder's Watchman those of us on the pro watchman's deep side,
contend that Zack Snyder, playfully twists Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons,
Seminole comic injecting his own signature style to satirize pop culture and
comic book films. Nowadays. However,
those of us that think watchman's dumb claim Snyder not only completely missed
the point of Moore's graphic novel, but betrays,
everything Watchman originally stood for. So who's right. Well, let's dig in,
in this wisecrack condition on Zack Snyder's Watchman deep or dumb,
but before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor mischief.
If you don't know what mischief is,
it's a company that releases drops every two weeks ranging from viral digital
experiences to high price items.
That means in the past they've dropped Jesus' shoes,
a $1,425 pair of sneakers with Holy water in the souls that sold out instantly
and were subsequently featured on late night with Seth Meyers,
a text message bot that generates AI feet picks and the office Slack,
where they recreated all 201 episodes of the office inside of Slack,
just as if Michael and Dwight were working together in 2020,
none of their drops have ever been the same.
So you never know what you're going to get.
You may have seen some of these go viral on Reddit or even cable news.
So here's how you can get access to their future drops before anyone else.
They recently released an app to allow fans to get drops early drops can sell
out within seconds.
So the earlier you can get access to the better chance you'll have to secure a
drop fans will also be able to access exclusive drops twice a month and see what
items have been dropped in the past. So download the mischief app today,
by going to M S C H f.com.
That's M S C H f.com or search S C H F in the app store or
on Google play. And now back to the show, a quick note, before we begin,
there are three different cuts of Watchman available for the purposes of this
video. We're going to go with Zack Snyder and analyze his preferred version.
For me, the director's cut is really the, you know, which has the house's death.
And.
All right, let's get into a quick recap.
The film opens in an alternate timeline where the emergence of anonymous heroes
has dramatically changed the world. As we know it,
the U S won the Vietnam war and Richard Nixon is now serving his third term as
president in 1985,
but cold war tensions between the Soviets and the us have reached a tipping
point each side on the precipice of firing nuclear warheads,
making things worse. Former vigilantes are beginning to mysteriously die.
The comedian and early mass Touro is found dead flung from his apartment window.
The murder prompts,
another mask vigilante war shack to investigate and warn other prominent crime
fighters of the impending danger. These include night owl, silk Spectre,
Ozymandias, and the Superman himself.
Dr. Manhattan turns out all these murders were a distraction.
Ozymandias says master plan to kill millions of people and frame Dr.
Manhattan,
why you might ask well to unite the Soviet union and the United States against a
common enemy, thus averting nuclear Holocaust. Now,
before we can determine if Snyder either betrays or skillfully adapts Watchman,
first,
we need to understand the comic book that serves as its basis at its core.
Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons Watchman is a deconstruction of superhero comics.
Comics prior to Watchman were made in the bronze age,
which came directly after and largely mimic the silver age a time when they were
at their height of popularity yet were stifled by government regulation during
the silver age of the comics code,
censored them so that they had to adhere to strident rules,
advocating that good should always triumph over evil and forbidding any sexual
perversion or excessive violence. The bronze age,
largely replicated many tropes of the silver age though.
It's comics were darker and more Laden with social commentary. However,
by the 1980s,
comics were beginning to more meaningfully Belle against these restrictions
giving way to Watchman, which obliterated these rules altogether.
Watchman depicts a world where things aren't black and white,
the so-called heroes are morally conflicted and sometimes downright awful.
Even the villains nefarious plot is all in the name of averting nuclear
Armageddon. Just take it from Alan Moore. I think with things like Watchman,
if they succeed it's because they transcend the superhero genre,
they take it somewhere.
It had not been previously been the more hopeless the genre, the better really,
because people are going to be more surprised if you do something been good with
it.
Zack Snyder's Watchman emerged at a similar period names say comic superhero
films had been dominating the pop culture landscape X-Men Spiderman and leader
Ironman ushered in a resurgence of family-friendly superheroes at the multiplex.
These films dominated the box office in turn leading to darker more adult
superhero stories like the dark night.
So the time was seemingly perfect for Snyder to obliterate the family-friendly
reputation of superhero films and adapt to Watchman,
not as they sat higher up comic books,
but of comic book movies Snyder does so by filling his version of Watchman with
graphic violence, most superhero films issue the inherent violence,
their so called heroes because Batman punches folks, senselessly, Ironman,
blasts, bad guys with his res. And yet we never saw any of the carnage.
These violent acts would naturally because everything is a hundred percent PG
13, but in Watchman, we see everything take for instance,
the scene we're Dan and Lori are attacked by a gang in an alleyway in the comic.
This scene is just Dan and Lori punching a few goons.
We see a few bloodied faces a broken arm, but that's it in Snyder's version.
However,
this seems depicted in exacting detail detail that YouTube will probably flag us
for showing uncensored, sorry.
One could argue that all this Gore was intentional Snyder commenting on the dark
nature of the film said what's popular about the dark night is that it's a
superhero movie at its core. When Batman puts on his costume that's bad. Yeah.
Batman go kick some. Watchman is an entirely different experience.
It punishes the audience. It says, Oh, you like the comedian, Oh, he's a rapist.
By the way,
I wanted people to think it's going to be a standard superhero movie.
And then they're confronted by all these ideas by showcasing.
This violence Snyder draws attention to how comic book films refuse to
acknowledge the destruction and darkness implicit.
To the idea of vigilantism satirizing superhero films,
just as more did to comics before him. So pretty deep, right?
Well, look,
there's no denying that Zack Snyder is a gifted filmmaker who can stage an
action sequence like no other,
but these intricate fights are significant departure from the graphic novel,
which in comparison is fairly light on action. Yes,
of course there are fight scenes scattered throughout the book,
but they're always depicted in hyper realistic fashion, quick, brutal,
and over in less than a page or two or three more here,
lampoons the typical long-winded elegantly staged superhero fight by depicting
what these fights would actually look like in reality, by contrast,
as you tuber captain Christian notes,
the most vivid depiction of violence comes not from traditional superhero
antics, but as a result of Ozymandias is destruction of New York.
More never wanted to glorify watchman's heroes or their antics.
When heroes look back on their past, it's a pathetic form of nostalgia.
The comic even frequently invokes a perfume called nostalgia to drive the point
home as such all the present day fight scenes in the comic deliberately don't
match the rose-tinted way. The supers view their past heroics.
The best example of this is Hollis Mason's death, more juxtaposes Mason,
getting beat to death with the old man flashing back to his glory days,
beating up the baddies and saving the day yet in the present reality,
not a single punch of the elderly Hollis has shown only his fantasies of
youthful violence. However, in Snyder's version of Hollis Mason's death,
the elder crime fighter goes out with a bang landing,
a series of punches and dying with a kind of macho dignity.
The fight scene only reinforces Mason's Rose tinted vision of his past.
He really was just as heroic as he thinks he was,
which is the antithesis of what more was saying in the comic,
like giving us a veritable show of bad-assery Snyder.
Doesn't so much as subvert the genre. He reinforces it.
Whereas the comic was anti nostalgia. The film is adamantly pro nostalgia.
When silk Spectre a night owl Don their capes. Again,
it's a moment of triumphant Snyder's version.
They're even hero shots of the two, the comic feature soak spectra night.
I will reliving their glory days by having a nerdy discussion about how to
accommodate fire victims by moving a steering column,
the rescue culminates and them serving coffee to their wards by contrast Snyder
has night owl epically shred a water tower with a Gatling gun
while so expect her does a bonafide superhero landing super hero landing.
So you're going to do a super hero landing.
Whereas the comic depicts an impotent nerd needing to play with his gadgets to
feel like a man,
the film cures this impotence with actual bad-assery by glorifying these
superheroes,
both in the present and past Snider undercuts the moral ambiguity of the
original Watchmen glossing over many of the less desirable traits of the
characters take roar, shack, a character,
the anarchist more created to make fun of Steve did CO's iron ran inspired.
The question more portrays Worshack is a misanthrope who's obsessed with other
people. He reads the new frontiersman,
a far-right paper that supports the KKK echoes Reagan era talking points about
welfare Queens called silk Spectre, a bloated aging,
and just generally stands for everything that more personally detests Snyder
keeps a few of these flourishes.
The first silk Spectre is a bloated aging.
It's mostly to the more appealing nihilistic journal entries.
Even the questionable comments,
roar shack makes are repurposed in Snyder's version. For instance,
in the comics and the movie roar shack speculates.
If Ozymandias could be a homosexual,
this was meant to be more of a critique on war shacks obsession with so-called
deviant sex, but in Snyder's version were shacks.
Belief is taken as fact Ozymandias is revealed to have a hidden file on his
computer labeled boys,
thus roar shacks worldview is given more extra legitimacy instead of the morally
complex weirdo from the comics,
roar shack becomes the voice of reason and the audience surrogate of Snyder's
film. So we're stuck in a bit of a stalemate between deeper dump,
which means only one thing.
Watchman may have started.
Out as just a Lampoon on the superhero genre, but as more wrote the series,
it began to become something far deeper.
Watchman started off as a silly superhero story.
But what I eventually came to the conclusion of about Watchman was the most
important thing in it, was it structured. And I think at the end,
that Watchman structure was what it was about.
It was about a certain way of viewing reality.
It was about a kind of perception,
which I think was perhaps not as prominent in 1985 as it is now.
And as I think it will be in the near future,
it's not a linear perception of things that we do increasingly have in the 21st
century, see more wanted to challenge reader's perception.
He believed in a post relativity slash Einstein world time could no longer be
considered a linear construct.
How we perceive the world was inherently incomplete events don't occur linearly,
but are happening simultaneously through the structure of Watchman and in
particular through Dr.
Manhattan and Ozymandias more sought to prove this point just as Dr. Manhattan
views time,
non-linearly the comic is structured so that the past present and future are
constantly blurring together.
We tried to make Watchman structured that images recur all the way through
linking the present with the past and the future giving foreshadowings of things
that have yet to come giving echoes of things that have already happened.
And later on the comic Ozymandias watches events unfurl on multiple television
screens mirroring how a person would read the comic itself.
Adrian Vite is watching six channels at once.
And so at various points in Watchman are the readers it's multichannel viewing
by exposing readers to a non-linear comic book,
more sought to challenge how readers perceive their own reality. Similarly,
Snyder uses his version of Watchman to comment on the same, except for Snyder.
Isn't interested in how time and space shape perceptions of reality. Instead,
the filmmakers zeroes in on how pop culture and media have warped people's
perceptions with their comic Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons were saying,
superheroes are kind of funky aren't they,
we build upon that with a movie that acknowledges that superhero movies have
affected pop culture to prove this point,
Snyder fills Watchman with touchstones, from pop culture,
with one crucial addition superheroes by doing so Snyder.
Lateralizes the impact of comic book films on viewers showing how the emergence
of superheroes changes,
familiar moments in pop culture that we all know and remember Watchman almost
super imposes its heroes on your world,
which then changes how you view your world through its prison.
That's the genius of this book. That's what we try and do in the movie.
The movie is a challenge, sort of like the book is a challenge to your icons,
your morality, how you perceive pop culture, how you perceive mythology.
And for that matter, how you perceive God,
everything in Watchman is filtered through pop culture, even history itself.
When Dr. Manhattan fights in the Vietnam war.
[Inaudible].
That recreates this historical moment through the prism of the most famous
Vietnam war movie ever made apocalypse.
Now using the same music cue from Coppola's.
[Inaudible].
Later Snyder uses his soundtrack choices to reference the art film Koyaanisqatsi
life out of balance
That non-narrative film juxtaposes,
beautiful scenes of nature with the chaos of modern life,
and to have choice for a man who left earth because of the mayhem of humanity.
[Inaudible].
Even the war room Richard Nixon and his generals use is modeled.
After a famous film.
You can find in here, this is the war room.
All these examples expose how we perceive and filter the world through media and
pop culture.
It's not just a meadow wink that Hollis Mason has a copy of Moore's Watchmen on
his shelf. It's yet another example of how pop culture,
a comic book like Watchman influenced and shaped Snyders. And by proxy,
our perception of the world,
this theme culminates with Ozymandias watching dozens of TV screens allow the
comic book, but unlike Moore's original intent,
Ozymandias watching these screens mirroring how viewers read the comic Snyder
instead uses this moment to play on how reality is warped by pop culture,
all the images on the screen,
reference different films and programs that influence and shape Zack Snyder.
The filmmaker there's road, warrior Looney tunes.
The day the earth stood still fail safe and more.
So what are we to make of Snyder's Watchman as the filmmaker betrayed
everything.
Alan Moore's comics stood for glorifying its heroes and compromising the moral
ambiguity of Moore's work,
or has Snyder skillfully adapted Watchman for our pop culture saturated time.
Ultimately, it all depends on your perception. If you view Watchman,
the lens of Moore's original intent, then watchman's pretty dumb.
But if you view the film through Snyder signature style envision,
then the film could be considered deep. Even after all this,
we're still pretty split on the merits of this movie, but for what it's worth,
I tend to lean toward the deep side.
Whereas many of our writers lean towards dumb,
but honestly I can see both sides.
So what do you think is Watchman deep or dumb?
Has your perception of the film changed at all?
Let us know in the comments below,
thanks to all our patrons for supporting the channel and our podcast.
Don't forget to subscribe and we'll catch you next time guys. And before you go,
don't forget to check out mischiefs new app, go to [inaudible] dot com.
Click the link in the description,
or just search M S C H F in the app store or on Google play. And as always,
thanks for watching guys.
[Inaudible].